[Applauso]
immaginate di avere a disposizione una
macchina del tempo e di poter viaggiare
a vostro piacimento nelle diverse epoche
che ci hanno preceduto
avremo la possibilità di vedere di
persona ciò che noi oggi possiamo solo
immaginare ciò che ci è stato trasmesso
attraverso quei mezzi di comunicazione
che i nostri avi avevano a disposizione
ma ogni epoca aveva le sue priorità ed i
suoi messaggi da veicolare la
comunicazione non era mai fine a se
stessa ma aveva un utilità aveva uno
scopo
infine ed i mezzi erano soltanto dei
mezzi gli uomini delle caverne per
comunicare utilizzavano scolpire i loro
messaggi
prevalentemente si preoccupavano di
trasmettere informazioni sulla caccia
perché sopravvivere era l'impresa più
difficile
col passare dei secoli diventò più
semplice gli egizi per esempio non
utilizzavano più la comunicazione per
dare informazioni si dedicarono invece
alla realizzazione delle piramidi
più è grande la piramide più importante
il faraone e anche questa è una forma di
comunicazione
dispendiosa non alla portata di tutti
fatta sulla pelle di milioni di schiavi
ma anche questa comunicazione i romani
usarono l'esercito per comunicare agli
altri popoli la loro forza gli
imperatori comunicano con il popolo
attraverso la lotta dei gladiatori e
mostrando la grandezza delle loro regge
ma certo direte voi anche questa è una
forma di comunicazione in mano a pochi e
così sarà per tutto il medioevo sino a
quando con rinascimento non arrivarono i
primi influenze sì perché i vari cimabue
giotto leonardo michelangelo raffaello
caravaggio non sono altro che i
predecessori dei moderni influenze certo
internet ancora non esisteva ma avevano
i loro strumenti per per farsi conoscere
e per comunicare come la pittura la
scultura
si parla per lo più di chiesa di papi è
vero ma quello che conta non è questo
quello che conta è l'utilizzo di un
mezzo per comunicare un messaggio
oggi nulla è cambiato tutto e
comunicazione nello studio nell'amore
nel lavoro è impossibile pensare che
nella vita non sia centrale la
comunicazione ma io non sono qui per
dirvi come farlo quanto per raccontarvi
di come mi sono reso conto in questo
anno e mezzo di quanto la comunicazione
sia centrale nel percorso di ciascuno di
noi e di come quando circa un anno e
mezzo fa assieme ad un gruppo di ragazzi
e ragazze abbiamo dato vita alla più
giovane candidatura a sindaco di roma
nella storia della repubblica italiana
allerta spoiler non abbiamo vinto
ma secondo me non abbiamo neanche perso
in fondo eravamo solo un gruppo di
ragazzi con la voglia di combattere la
retorica del i giovani non sono più
quelli di una volta
oppure
dimostrare che non è vero che i giovani
sono il futuro perché i giovani sono il
presente è che per determinare il futuro
ci deve incidere in questo presente
allora abbiamo sfruttato tutti gli
strumenti di comunicazione che avevamo a
nostra disposizione per provare a dare
una voce a chi una voce non l'aveva mai
avuta
eravamo sui principali giornali nelle
televisioni nelle radio sul web
ma qual è la principale
piattaforma di comunicazione
utilizzata dalla generazione z sono i
social
allora mentre preparavo il mio
intervento di oggi ho
raccolto una lista fatto una lista di
tutte le piattaforme social su cui noi
eravamo e che abbiamo utilizzato per la
campagna elettorale
pensate noi eravamo contemporaneamente
su facebook instagram twitter youtube
tik tok talon intuisce federale di
scorda scapin 3 scuola thriller vero
telegram link di snapshot club house mi
fermo qua non li conoscete tutti eh no
pensate avevamo persino una colonna
sonora dedicata alla campagna elettorale
pubblicata su spotify con tanto di
playlist per ogni evento
ma d'altronde così la politica è così se
fai qualcosa ma quella cosa non la
racconti vuol dire che non l'hai mai
fatta
ed oggi anche ai grandi della politica
tocca adattarsi
vi porto un esempio
mi hanno detto che non posso fare nomi
quindi mi limito a dire un leader di un
partito francese che non ha vinto le
elezioni
ma che ha fatto una cosa fantastica
in pratica mentre lui parlava in un
posto così come sto facendo qui oggi con
voi
aveva un avatar virtuale in altre 25
città della francia che replicava il suo
intervento
ora non so se voi siate come me fan
della saga di star wars ma sembrava obi
wan kenobi che guarda il video messaggio
della principessa leila da r2 d2 una
figata
tutto ciò chiaramente non gioca sempre a
favore di chi veicola il messaggio
anzi oggi viene chiesta la politica una
maggiore coerenza e puoi stare certo del
fatto che se in un'occasione hai detto
qualcosa di diverso da ciò che stai
dicendo oggi qualcuno te lo farà più o
meno educatamente notare e allora gli
stessi canali di comunicazione che hai
utilizzato per promuover t
all'improvviso ti si ritorcono contro
ciò giusto o sbagliato che sia e mi
riferisco alla
legittima possibilità che ha ciascuno di
noi di cambiare idea è dovuto a un
cambiamento del paradigma della politica
avvenuto negli ultimi anni
prima di parlarne però vorrei farvi
qualche domanda per alzata di mano
quanti di voi credono nella politica
i ragazzi ho fatto la stessa domanda
durante le prove c'erano più mani alzate
eravamo in tre
vabbè case comanda a questo punto quanti
di voi fanno politica
perché perché se dice di sé che dice chi
ci crede perché la fa altrimenti in anno
all'altro è ok questa va beh la faccia
ma tanto chi di voi crede che i politici
siano di parola nemmeno lei questa volta
è vedere il tema è proprio questo la
mancanza di coerenza tra la propria
comunicazione politica e ciò che viene
fatto ha portato a creare una distanza
siderale tra i politici e chi con il
loro voto gli ha permesso di essere le
io vedo la politica come un orchestra
un'orchestra che suona uno spartito
a volte i musicisti sono bravi
altre volte no i tempi cambiano e vero e
cambiano anche i protagonisti della
politica
oggi chiunque può farsene interprete i
cantanti fanno politica gli attori fanno
politica gli influencer fanno politica
persino le aziende prendono posizioni
politiche fare politica però è un atto
volto verso gli altri non verso se
stessi siamo tutti per la pace nel mondo
ma fare politica significa dire cose con
cui qualcuno può non essere d'accordo
significa studiare approfondire un tema
e non limitarsi a comunicare un
messaggio
superficiale che tutti condivideranno
fare una live su instagram con chi al
nostro stesso punto di vista significa
spalleggiarsi non confrontarsi
siamo nel mese del pride quante aziende
hanno colorato i propri loghi arcobaleno
per dimostrare la loro vicinanza alla
comunità lgbt cui plus e quante di loro
sono state bene attente però e l'hanno
fatto solamente nei profili del mercato
legato agli stati uniti all'europa ma
non l'hanno fatto in quei canali
utilizzati per la comunicazione in medio
oriente e proprio lì dove ce ne sarebbe
stato più bisogno
e allora quanti si espongono su questi
temi perché ci credono e quanti invece
lo fanno per definire la loro immagine
la risposta la lascio a voi
quanto a noi la nostra storia velo
raccontata noi non abbiamo vinto ma non
abbiamo neanche perso battere i pugni
farsi sentire incalzare la politica ci
abbiamo provato ed in qualche modo siamo
riusciti a determinare il programma
elettorale
ad incidere sulle candidature giovani
nelle liste abbiamo usato gli strumenti
di comunicazione che avevamo a
disposizione e in qualche modo abbiamo
raggiunto un obiettivo
ma ciò che oggi ancora manca è una
coscienza di classe io credo che i
giovani siano una classe sociale ma che
non collaborino abbastanza e non
agiscano nel loro interessi come
categoria
parlarne utile ma agire è fondamentale
non delegate le battaglie che per voi
sono importanti a qualcun altro non
servono palcoscenici per fare la
differenza ciascuno di noi ha la
possibilità di portare un cambiamento di
fare la differenza qui e ora
grazie
[Applauso]